S
WRINKLES. GOODBYE, NEUTROGENA.
OKAY, SO A TWEET FROM A MAJOR
LEAGUE BASEBALL PLAYER IS
SPARKING A FIERCE ONLINE DEBATE
ABOUT PARENTING. TORONTO BLUE
JAYS PITCHER ANTHONY BASS POSTED
THIS PHOTO ON TWITTER, SAYING
THAT A UNITED AIRLINES FLIGHT
ATTENDANT MADE HIS PREGNANT WIFE
GET ON HER HANDS AND KNEES TO
CLEAN UP A MESS MADE BY THEIR
TWO YEAR OLD DAUGHTER HAS
RESPONDED TO THE TWEET, SAYING
THEY UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN AND
ARE LOOKING INTO IT. SO HERE'S
THE QUESTION WHO'S RESPONSIBLE?
TO CLEAR RESPONSIBILITY. IS IT
RATHER SHOULD I SAY TO CLEAN UP
AFTER YOUR KIDS WHEN YOU'RE IN A
PUBLIC PLACE LIKE A PLANE OR A
RESTAURANT OR A MOVIE THEATER?
JOINING US NOW CNN OPINION
WRITER JEFF YANG AND OUTREACH
AND OPINION EDITOR FOR PENN LIVE
AND THE PATRIOT NEWS, JOYCE
DAVIS, WELCOME TO YOU BOTH JOE
JOYCE, LET ME START WITH YOU.
SIMPLE QUESTION. WHOSE
RESPONSIBILITY IS IT SHOULD THE
MOM HAVE HAD TO HAVE BEEN MADE
TO PICK UP THE POPCORN. WELL,
LOOK, CONTEXT IS EVERYTHING
RIGHT? AND I ALWAYS FALL DOWN ON
THE SIDE OF COMPASSION. SO IF
YOU JUST WANT A STRICT ANSWER,
YES, YOU SHOULD MAKE SURE THAT
YOU THINK, BUT THE WOMAN WAS
PREGNANT, RIGHT? SHE WAS COME ON
. LET'S GIVE A LITTLE SOME SOME
LITTLE COMPASSION HERE. SO
THAT'S I MEAN, BEING A PARENT IS
HARD. SO THAT'S ALL I'M SAYING.
YES YOU CAN FOLLOW THE RULE OF
THE LAW. BUT YOU ALSO LOOK LOOK
AT THE WORLD AND HELP HER. UM
OKAY, JEFF, PLEASE CHIME IN ON
THIS AND BY THE WAY, AND WHY
DIDN'T THEY ASK THE DAD TO PICK
UP AFTER THE CHILD'S MESS? BUT
ANYWAY, JEFF, WHOSE
RESPONSIBILITY WAS IT, THE
PARENTS OR THE FLIGHT ATTENDANT?
I MEAN, I HAD THE SAME THOUGHT
AS YOURSELF. WHERE WAS THE
DAMPNESS CIRCUMSTANCE? I THINK
HE WAS PROBABLY ON THE PITCHER'S
MOUND. BUT IN THIS CASE AND IN
OTHERS, I JUST REMEMBER MY OWN
PARENTS ALWAYS TELLING ME WELL,
YOU KNOW, YOU GUYS ARE BASICALLY
EXTENSION OF ME ANYTHING THAT
YOU DO MORE OR LESS REFLECTS ON
ME WHETHER YOU'RE BEING PRAISED
OR YOU'RE BEING PUNISHED AND
MAKING A MESS. UH WHETHER OR NOT
IT IS SOMETHING YOU INTENDED TO
DO OR NOT. IF YOU'RE IN THAT
SITUATION AS A PARENT, YOU DO
HAVE SOME RESPONSIBILITY TO
REFLECT ON. YOU KNOW THE NEEDS
THAT THE PEOPLE AROUND YOU HAVE
NOT JUST FOR YOUR OWN KIDS, SO I
AGREE WITH JOYCE. ABSOLUTELY THE
CONTEXT MATTERS, BUT YOU KNOW,
THE JOY OF HAVING KIDS TO BEGIN
WITH IS EXPERIENCING THE
PLEASURE AND PAIN PARENTING AND
ONE OF THEM IS PICKING UP AFTER
THEM. SO I AM YOU KNOW, YOU KNOW
HOW YOU WATCHED SESAME STREET
AND LIKE ONE OF THESE THINGS IS
NOT LIKE THE OTHERS. I'M NOT A
PARENT. I'M NOT A FATHER. I WILL
NEVER BE A FATHER. THE THREE OF
YOU ALL HAVE KIDS, RIGHT? SO I'M
JUST THE DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE.
BUT MY QUESTION IS SOMEBODY'S
GOT TO PICK UP THE POPCORN,
RIGHT? IT'S ALL I UNDERSTAND THE
COMPASSION, JOYCE. BUT IF THE
POPCORN WAS DROPPED BY THE KID,
EVEN COMPASSION, SAYS WHAT ABOUT
THE COMPASSION FOR THE FLIGHT
ATTENDANT WHO HAS SO MUCH TO DO?
ESPECIALLY IN THIS ENVIRONMENT
THAT WE'VE SEEN ALL OF THIS
HAPPENING ON PLANES? STILL HER
RESPONSIBILITY TO DO IT? YES.
YEAH. YEAH I HEAR I HEAR WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING. BUT THERE WOULD
HAVE BEEN A BIGGER
RESPONSIBILITY IF THAT PREGNANT
MOTHER HAD GOTTEN SICK OR HAD
HURT HERSELF RIGHT? THAT WOULD
BE EVEN MORE OF A RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THEM TO TAKE CARE OF HER. SO
THAT'S WHY I'M SAYING, YEAH, WE
CAN BE STRICT AND SAY I AGREE
WITH YOU. WE'VE GOT TO CONSIDER
OTHER PEOPLE AS A PARENT. AND AS
I SAID, I ALWAYS HAD HIGH
EXPECTATIONS FROM MY KIDS IN
PUBLIC RIGHT? AND HE ALWAYS
GENERALLY WELL BEHAVED. ALTHOUGH
THERE WAS SOMETIMES HE WASN'T
WELL BEHAVED. THERE WERE REASONS
FOR IT. SO WE HAVE TO. REALLY I
MEAN, THIS IS PART OF SOCIETY IN
GENERAL TO GIVE EACH OTHER MORE
GRACE. WE'VE GOT TO BE KINDER.
WE'VE GOT TO BE MORE HELPING TO
EACH OTHER. AND IT IS THE FLIGHT
ATTENDANTS RESPONSIBILITY TO
CLEAN THE PLANE. I MEAN, THERE'S
THAT'S THEIR JOB. THEY'RE BEING
PAID TO DO IT. NO MATTER WHAT
HAPPENS IN THIS CASE, I'M NOT
DISAGREEING WITH YOU. THINK OF
THE IMPACT THE PEOPLE AROUND
YOU. BUT LET'S BE NICE. I HEAR A
SWELL OF FLIGHT ATTENDANTS,
SAYING IT'S NOT OUR JOB TO CLEAN
THE PLANE, YOU KNOW, AND LOOK.
YOU KNOW, I DO. TAKE THE FLIGHT
ATTENDANTS. YOU KNOW, I SEE
THEIR PERSPECTIVE AS WELL. BUT
ALSO AS A PARENT, YOU KNOW, WHAT
ARE WE TEACHING OUR CHILDREN
WHEN IT COMES TO RESPECT FOR
OTHERS AND RESPONSIBILITY FOR
YOUR ACTIONS, RIGHT? MAYBE TWO
YEAR OLD TWO YEARS OLD IS TOO
YOUNG. I DON'T KNOW THAT MY SON
WAS ALMOST THREE WOULD MEAN I
WOULD ASK HIM TO PICK UP AFTER
HIMSELF. BUT IF MY FIVE YEAR OLD
DAUGHTER MADE A MESS UNDER HER
SEAT, I WOULD TAKE OFF HER SEAT
BELT. I WILL TELL HER GET ON THE
FLOOR ON YOUR HANDS AND KNEES
AND PICK IT UP BECAUSE I MEAN
KIDS CAN MAKE A RIDICULOUS MESS.
I'VE BEEN TO RESTAURANTS WHERE
I'VE SEEN PARENTS JUST SITTING
THERE AND THERE IS FOOD ALL
AROUND THE TABLE. I HAVE GOTTEN
ON MY HANDS AND KNEES AND
CLEANED UP AFTER MY KIDS, AND SO
HAS MY HUSBAND. I HAVE NO SHAME
IN THAT. BUT FOR ME, IT'S ABOUT
TEACHING MY KIDS. HEY. THIS IS
YOUR MESS. YOU BETTER PICK UP
AFTER YOURSELF. AND LOOK, WE
WEREN'T THERE. WE DON'T KNOW THE
CONTEXT OF THE FLIGHT ATTENDANT
REALLY SAID. GET ON YOUR HANDS
AND KNEES AND PICK UP. UM BUT I
MEAN, JEFF, I MEAN, DO YOU AGREE
WITH AT LEAST THAT WE SHOULD BE
TEACHING OUR CHILDREN THAT IT IS
THEIR RESPONSIBILITY TO CLEAN UP
AFTER THEMSELVES? I AM TOTALLY
WITH YOU AT THE SAME TIME
RECOGNIZING THAT KIDS AND I HAVE
TWO BOYS AT THAT AGE ABSOLUTELY
ARE LIKE PUPPIES. THEY WILL KIND
OF DESTROY THINGS FOR REALLY NO
PURPOSE. I WAS IN A VERY SIMILAR
CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE MY TWO BOYS
WHILE I WAS SORT OF DOZING OFF
ON A PLANE ACTUALLY RIPPED UP
COCKTAIL NAPKINS AND CREATED
KIND OF CONFETTI EVERYWHERE. AND
I HAVE THE END OF THAT, UH, TOLD
THEM THEY HAD TO CLEAN IT UP.
THEY COULDN'T LEAVE IT FOR OTHER
PEOPLE AND KIND OF MADE A GAME
OF IT. YOU KNOW, ALL OF THIS
KIND OF GOT ON OUR KNEES, TRYING
TO PICK UP AS MANY AS POSSIBLE
AND SEEING WHO GOT THE MOST, BUT
YOU KNOW, FUNDAMENTALLY, EVEN IF
MY YOUNGER KID WAS TOO SMALL TO
DO IT, MY OLDER KID AGAIN YOU
SAID THERE WAS A FIVE YEAR OLD
SITTING THERE RIGHT NOW. YEAH. I
WAS OLD ENOUGH TO DO SOMETHING
AND IT'S JUST PART OF WHAT WE
HAVE TO DO. I'M WITH YOU BOTH,
THOUGH YOU KNOW, BECAUSE JOYCE,
I DO HEAR YOU. WHEN YOU SAY
LET'S YOU KNOW WE NEED TO GIVE
EACH OTHER MORE GRACE AND
COMPASSION AND GUESTS. YOU KNOW,
MAYBE SHE WASN'T FEELING SO WELL
AND YOU KNOW, IT SUCKS BEING
PREGNANT. SO YOU KNOW, I
DEFINITELY SEE ALL SIDES OF
THIS. THAT YOUNG POPCORN WAS
GOING TO SAY THAT WELL, NO, BUT
IT'S ALSO AN IT'S DANGER. YOU
DON'T WANT YOUR NOT SUPPOSED TO
GIVE YOUR KIDS POPCORN AT TWO
BECAUS